haben wir in unserem sonnensystem einen
weiteren planeten entdeckt den bis jetzt
noch niemand gesehen hat
zwei wissenschaftler aus kalifornien
haben die bisher stärksten hinweise auf
diesen ominösen neunten planeten
gefunden
er soll 200 bis 1200 mal weiter von der
sonne entfernt sein als wir selber und
ist wahrscheinlich ungefähr so schwer
wie neptun oder zehn mal so schwer wie
die erde
der vermutete planet unseres
sonnensystems ist so weit von uns
entfernt dass er 10.000 bis 20.000 jahre
braucht um einmal um die sonne zu
kreisen
die wissenschaftler vermuten auch dass
planet ixia genannt wird auf einer stark
elliptischen bahn kreis und an den
wendepunkten bis zu 180 milliarden
kilometer von der sonne entfernt ist
aber noch kein grund zum feiern denn
alles ist es jetzt nur theoretisch den
beiden wissenschaftlern sind eigentlich
nur sechs objekte in puebla drittel
aufgefallen die sehr komische bahnen
fliegen
nach weiteren untersuchungen stellte
sich heraus dass ein sehr massereicher
körper wie zum beispiel ein planet alle
anomalien perfekt erklärt da die bahnen
der anderen objekte beeinflussen würde
die wissenschaftler machen dann was
viele wissenschaftler mit einer
brisanten neuen theorie tun
sie versuchten das gegenteil zu beweisen
und scheiterten damit bisher gesehen
wurde der mysteriöse planet zwar noch
nicht allerdings so die wissenschaftler
müsste dies mit heutigen technologien
bereits möglich sein und vielleicht
versteckt sich der planet sogar im
weltall bildern die bereits aufgenommen
wurden
es gibt eine wahrscheinlichkeit von 0,0
0 7% oder 1 zu 150000 dass die bahnen
der anderen himmelskörper zufällig auf
diese weise beeinflusst wurden
das klingt für uns war ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich reicht wissenschaftlern
aber normalfall nicht aus eine
wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 1 7
millionen während ihr besser
deswegen sind auch viele andere
wissenschaftler noch nicht bereit den
beiden zu glauben man müsste weitere
untersuchungen anstellen und im
optimalfall den planeten auch wirklich
durch ein teleskop beobachten können ehe
man ihn als neuen planeten unseres
sonnensystems erklärt falls der planet
gerade am äußersten ende seiner
umlaufbahn ist bräuchte man
wahrscheinlich eines der größten
teleskope der erde wie zum beispiel das
subaru teleskop in hawaii um ihn
betrachten zu können falls er mehr an
uns und der sonne ist sollten auch
andere für das gruppe in der lage sein
ihnen zu sehen
es wäre nicht das erste mal dass man
planeten so weit von ihrem stern
entfernt findet das weltraumteleskop
kepler findet regen mehr
planeten mit riesigen abständen zu ihren
sonnen es ist also durchaus möglich dass
es einen oder sogar mehrere planeten da
draußen gibt die um unsere sonne kreisen
und damit zu unserem sonnensystem
gehören und auch die methode ist nicht
neu neptun wurde 1846 nur entdeckt weil
uranus von seiner berechneten bahn
abwich und ein großes objekt ihn
anziehen musste die chancen stehen also
nicht schlecht dass wir bald das erste
mal seit 2006 zum zwergplaneten
degradiert wurde wieder neuen planeten
in unserem sonnensystem haben und um
sich bis dahin die zeit zu vertreiben
das internet fieberhaft nach einem namen
für den neuen planeten hoch im kurs
stehen weiterhin griechische götter alle
gossau thun nibiru und marburg sind im
rennen
ich persönlich wäre er für was cooles
nabu alderaan endor oder wie man ihn
direkt einfach tolle stern die coole
tasten helfen unseren eigenen todesstern
im sonnensystem
wie würdet ihr auch einen planeten
nennen schreibt hier unten in die
kommentare bin schon sehr gespannt was
dafür nahm warum kommen und wenn euch
neuigkeiten wie diese hier interessieren
dann solltet ihr auch noch facebook oder
twitter folgen denn es passieren jeden
tag so viele coole dinge im bereich der
wissenschaft und in anderen bereichen
da kann ich nicht jedes mal wieder
darüber machen aber bei coolen sachen
halte ich euch auf social media immer
auf dem laufenden also checkt die video
beschreibung und ansonsten viel spaß
bis zum nächsten mal